The universe is vast and full of mystery and
one that has been puzzling astronomers for a
while now is fast radio bursts. And I mean I
get it, how am I supposed to make this thing
go fast or burst? Nope. Luckily I have an
astronomer waiting for me in an elevator
to explain it all in the time it takes to go
up to the top and back down again. Let's go.
Hey Manisha. Hey Rad.
So I know we're talking space, we're talking
astronomy, we're talking fast radio bursts.
That is correct. All right let's get into it. What
is a fast radio burst? Fast radio bursts, or FRBs
as we refer to them, are these extremely energetic
flashes in the sky that last about a hundred times
quicker than the blink of an eye. However they're
invisible to the naked eye because they emit at
the range of colors outside what the human eye
can perceive. Okay, but where do they come from?
Now the furthest known FRB was produced 8 billion
years ago and in comparison our solar system
is only 4.6 billion years old, this means that
when the light left the source we did not exist.
So the Solar System, the Earth, life on Earth,
humans, we all came about while the signal was
traveling to us. But wait, you said that it was
light but it's not light it's radio waves? It's
radio light so it's not in the visible part
of the spectrum that you can see but they're
outside the red to blue rainbow colors. Oka.
But what caused them? Could it be aliens?
We know of about 50 theories for what these
could be. But the current leading favorite are
magnetars so these are these extremely energetic
objects which have massive and powerful magnetic
fields. So what are the implications of FRBs?
Like why do they matter? What's interesting is
the signal bears the imprint of the medium
that it travels through so the FRB encodes
information about everything in its path. So
as a result the radio data are a gold mine of
information and this in fact helped us locate the
missing matter in the universe. What do you mean
missing matter? So 95 per cent of the universe
is dark energy and dark matter and five per cent
is normal matter but 50 per cent of this normal
matter is only accounted for and the remaining
50 per cent was considered missing until very
recently. How is it missing? How can we just
not know where it is? It's matter. So in a sense
it's invisible because it doesn't emit or glow or
absorb light but it does slow down radio waves
which is where FRBs come in. Have we found all
of it? We have found all of it. So it's consistent
with what we theorised but we don't know how it's
distributed. There's always a 'but'. There is
always a 'but', that's what research is. Well
thank you for teaching me about FRBs. So let me
start with what we do know. Fast radio bursts
are bursts of extremely energetic radio waves.
Think FM radio but way way bigger and we kind of
know where they come from. We have observed at
least once that they come from magnetars which
are a type of neutron star but other than that we
don't know what produces them. The other reason
why they're really interesting is we can use
these fast radio bursts to give us information
about matter in the universe and the way that
we do that is by comparing long and short wave
bursts that come from the same origin point and
calculate how long it takes for them to arrive at
us now when they pass through matter that's going
to slow them down and depending on the material
it'll slow them down by a different amount.
So we basically can look at all of that and
figure out what's out there and in doing this
we have managed to find a whole lot of matter
that we just thought was missing which is pretty
cool. I'm gonna be thinking about that every time
I listen to the radio now. Hey there, thanks for
watching. If you liked this video you can see more
Elevator Pitch here or you could subscribe below
for more videos from ABC Science. And if you're
keen to uncover more cosmological mysteries
then stream Catalyst on ABC iview. [Music]